Bart lobenstein is a sleepy town in the
Eastern German state of thuringia and
yet in this Castle police say the
alleged plotters would meet to discuss
their plans and store their weapons it
belongs to heinle Royce a minor
Aristocrat who Styles himself as Prince
Heinrich the 13th but who investigators
believe is the ringleader of the group a
man long denounced by his family and by
other townspeople for espousing
conspiracy theories
our citizens of bad lobenstein received
a letter this past summer in which we
were told that we were not German
because our passports were not German we
were then given the opportunity to apply
for our German origin documents with
what the sender called the Royce
Administration the driving ideology of
the Royce group is from the far right
rice Burger tradition it would do away
with democracy and reimpose the
imperialist rule by a monarch or Kaiser
many thousands of people have a loose
and not Criminal affiliation to The
Wider principle but very few have
actively plotted to bring it about
convince people are can be very strange
in Germany can be very radical and can
be violent we have seen that in our
history and this is the very reason that
the big majority of the people say not
again certainly the mood among many
Germans is one of incredulity
[Music]
it's not really comprehensible you hear
about such plans in other countries but
for this to happen outside my front door
the government we have is not ideal but
probably better than what they had
planned
to be honest I have no words it's so far
away from what I personally believe in
so I find it hard to grasp
one central question being asked is how
some of the alleged plotters could have
reached positions of relative power and
influence in society another question is
what the country should do to remove
such people from Office earlier
the most important consequence of this
is that everyone knows that we have a
true State and a defensible democracy
which is able with its security
authorities to thwart such violations of
the law and repel them with all its
might
Bryce Burgers have a love-hate
relationship with this building as the
bundestag or federal Parliament it's a
demonstration of a democratic Germany
they would abandon but as the old rice
tags building it's a reminder of the
Imperial Germany they would bring back
for now ministers say they've thwarted
that ambition
Dominic Kane Al Jazeera Berlin